bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite votre si les grands titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 2 décembre
après six mois d'auditions la commission
d' enquête parlementaire de l'assemblée
rend son verdict sur la gestion des
crises du coc vide les députés pointent
un pilotage défaillant et accable le
gouvernement demain le premier ministre
détaillera la stratégie vaccinale
française alors que la grande bretagne
vient de donner son autorisation au
vaccin 16h by one tech et que vladimir
poutine demande de débuter la
vaccination de masse dès la fin de
semaine prochaine en russie apaiser les
tensions cristallisé autour de l'article
24 tel était l'objectif d' emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui gérard larcher gérard
larcher et les chefs de groupes
parlementaires du sénat était est invité
à déjeuner à l'elysée
la commission des lois de l'assemblée va
réécrire l'article controversé d'ici 15
jours
quant à la commission indépendante mise
en place par jean castex
elle fera des propositions sur les
relations entre la presse et forces de
sécurité
l'afer est clair plusieurs médias
étrangers s'en sont fait l'écho belgique
espagne suisse ou encore en angleterre
la diffusion des images de l'agression
d'un producteur noire à paris
interrogées inquiètent la presse
la france est elle en train de prendre
un virage autoritaire ou encore peut-on
parler d'une affaire de georges floyd à
la française outre-atlantique à c'est le
statu quo alors que le ministre de la
justice bulgare a déclaré ne pas avoir
constaté de fraude suffisantes pour
invalider la victoire de joe biden à la
présidentielle donald trump lui nie
toujours sa défaite
le locataire de la maison blanche qui
laisse tout de même entendre qu'il
pourrait bien se représenter en 2024
pour un second mandat
d
après six mois d'auditions la commission
d' enquête parlementaire de l'assemblée
nationale a donc adopté son rapport sur
la gestion de la crise du coc vite par
le gouvernement 200 pages accablantes
pour le gouvernement pour en parler nous
retrouvons tout de suite notre reporter
baisse chez be en direct depuis le
palais bourbon vont soir bassem quels
sont donc les conclusions de ce rapport
effectivement stéphanie vous l'avais dit
c'était un rapport accablant un rapport
à charge contre le gouvernement celui de
la commission d' enquête parlementaire
sur le co vide 19 piloté par les
républicains qui parle de
sous-estimation du risque ou encore de
pilotage défaillant de la crise alors
que de leur côté les députés et les rues
m
je préfère parler d'un rapport partiel
et partial et eric ciotti député et
l'eire qui est rapporteur de cette
commission
surenchérit et parle lui d'une gestion
chaotique lui qui vous ne polluez
voulait pas pardon transformer cette
commission en un tribunal comme il l'a
déclaré un rapport donc quand vous
l'avez dit adopté ce matin sans les voix
des députés aient les mêmes qui ont
préféré s abstenir je vous rappelle que
ces auditions qui ont duré plus de six
mois 50 audition au total 130 heures ont
été écouté énormément de personnalités
politiques des mondes du gouvernement
des ministres de la santé d'anciens
membres du gouvernement à l'image
d'edouard philippe l'ancien premier
ministre mais également des
personnalités issues du monde
scientifique à l'image du professeur
eric didier pardon didier raoul 96
plaintes ont été déposées contre le
gouvernement auprès de la cour de
justice de la république c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le député et chef de file des
républicains à l'assemblée nationale
monsieur abad il dénonce lui un manque
de d'anticipation des messages
complètement contradictoire il faisait
référence notamment à la problématique
autour du masque il a parlé également
des grands oubliés de cette crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19 notamment
concernant la première vague il parle
entre autres des maisons de retraite et
des personnes âgées
alors qu'eric ciotti et lui surenchérit
même et déclare que la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ne devraient pas révéler
révélée reuver pardon du ministère de la
santé mais plutôt du ministère de
l'intérieur voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur ce rapport du côté du sénat qui eux
ont leur propre commission d' enquête
concernant ce que vides
19 le sénat qui a majorité à droite on
craint que les conclusions de ce rapport
soient les mêmes que celles de
l'assemblée nationale le sénat qui
devrait examiner son rapport d'ici la
semaine prochaine
merci bassem chez billets pour en parler
nous sommes avec rôle à un crâne au lit
maire dvd de gagny en seine-saint-denis
bonsoir au lac ramolli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france tout
d'abord une première réaction à ce
rapport bonsoir
juste une petite précision je suis en
mer et l'air et non pas dvd donc
concernant ce rapport qui a été établi
par mail sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement en tant
que maire tous les maires ont eu à subir
en plus ce pilotage un petit peu à
l'instrument ou sans instrument où on
pourra dire parce que les consignes de
l'état n'était pas forcément hyper clair
ni pour la population ni pour les
collectivités territoriales
comment pour l'autorité territoriale que
nous mais nous représentons et là dessus
nous avons dû faire face à des des
annonces gouvernementales sur les
chaînes de télé une interprétation
ensuite faite par le premier ministre
dans les différents donc conférence de
presse qu'il a pu donner et enfin les
circulaire préfectorale qui n'avaient
pas forcément toujours dans le sens de
ce qui est annoncé par l'état et ça
c'est la même chose depuis le mois de
mars
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les connectivités on
va faire face à une crise qui tu es ma
chère pour notre population majeure pour
notre pays même majeurs au niveau
international avec les moyens qui sont
les nôtres en essayant de respecter tant
que possible les consignes qui sont
données par le gouvernement
et lorsque nous étions pas d'accord ici
choix que nous avions fait au niveau du
territoire grand paris gantès lorsque
nous étions pas d'accord avec les
directions prises par le gouvernement
plutôt que de prendre des arrêtés qui
irait à l'encontre des décisions du
gouvernement et rendre notre population
dans une m notre population dans une ère
d'incertitude et illégalité
nous avons fait le choix plusieurs
collègues et moi même de poursuivre les
différents arrêtés lorsque nous
désignons qui avait des failles sur ces
arrêtés et que ces arrêtés créer une
inéquité face aux services publics
alors les verdicts effectivement on le
disait et c'est vers la france était mal
armé face à la pandémie songe estimation
du risque épidémique c'est un diagnostic
que vous mer et l'air vous partagez je
le partage totalement effectivement la
france était était ma d'armé après à la
décharge du gouvernement il faut aussi
avoir pleinement conscience que cette
crise majeure était aussi inédite
inédite et le aucun gouvernement eux
dans le monde n'aurait pu anticiper 7,7
christ ensuite nous avons deux phases de
dépit des missions sur le coronavirus
ces deux femmes auraient pu nous servir
de leçon dès la première phase nous
aurons plus de tirs et les des ressorts
extrêmement concrètes sur la façon de
gérer la deuxième de la seconde phase
qui allait arriver qui était déjà prévu
qui était déjà prévue dès le
dès la fin de la première phase on
savait déjà que n'étant pas du tout à
l'abri
ben dans le confinement et de nouveaux
pics épidémiques
alors les membres l ère de la commission
se sont eux abstenus de voter un
contrairement aux républicains vous
faites partie veuillez nous excuser
d'ailleurs pour cette erreur de
présentation vous comprenez leur
réaction aux députés la reine qui
soutient évidemment l'exécutif ces
députés sont pris entre entre deux feux
ils ont pleinement conscience que tout
n'a pas été fait strictement comme il
devait être fait et comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure je ne suis pas là pour
taper sur le gouvernement le
gouvernement a fait ce qu'il a pu avec
les moyens qu'ils avaient ils auraient
pu faire certains d'autres choix et
c'est là dessus que je ne comprends pas
la réaction de certains députés et les
relais qui aurait pu faire preuve de
pragmatisme et se dire mais
effectivement en toute humilité nous
aurions pu faire différemment sur
certains points et admettre cela ne pas
l'admettre ne pas le voter juste
s'abstenir et se dire bah finalement bas
c'est très bien comme ça non cela ne
convient pas à la population cela nous
convient pas et là dessus heureusement
que dans notre pays nous sommes une
vraie démocratie que les groupes
d'opposition au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale ont pu faire valoir leur droit
de parole sur la gestion qui a été faite
par le gouvernement alors un effet du du
good grand paris est grand test dont
vous faites partie vous aussi ont décidé
d'attaquer en justice le décret sur la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
pour quelles raisons pour exactement les
mêmes raisons que nous avions attaqué
également le premier décret qui
interdisait les commerces non essentiels
de
d'ouvrir le gouvernement partait du
principe que certains commerçants ne
pouvait pas vrai parce que il ne
pourrait pas assurer la sécurité
sanitaire de leurs clients dans leurs
établissements alors que justement dans
ces petits commerces
les gérants de ces commerces avaient
pris toutes les mesures nécessaires au
même titre que les restaurateurs
aujourd'hui les restaurateurs
aujourd'hui sont vraiment les laissés
pour compte de cette gestion de crise
parce que avant de demander aux
restaurateurs de fermer le gouvernement
leur a demandé de fait de prendre tout
un tas de mesure d'investir pour pouvoir
assurer la sécurité sanitaire
avant de le dire dans un délai
extrêmement court bas à partir de telle
date vous allez le faire mais lui fermé
resteront pour pour moi il ya un manque
de logique austry aussi dans tout cela
parce que les différents restaurants
d'entreprise différents restaurants
scolaires qui existe dans les
établissements scolaires dans les
collèges dans les lycées restent ouverts
la population doit quand même pouvoir
continuer à se nourrir et les risques
que le gouvernement montre en avant pour
fermer les restaurants existe tout
autant dans les restaurants
d'entreprises dans les restaurants
scolaires
vous savez aussi pardonnez moi mais vous
savez aussi que voilà les les comptines
dans les entreprises sont plutôt réduit
vous savez bien que ça on brasse voilà
des gens dans un restaurant notamment
vous contestez cette dangerosité
je ne conteste pas cette dangerosité
parce que je ne suis pas médecin je sais
rester à ma place parce qu'il le faut je
demande simplement au conseil d'état au
même titre que mes collègues de
réanalyser ce décret pour voir si ce
décret ne crée pas une rupture d'équité
face
à la liberté d'entreprendre vis-à-vis
des restaurateurs merci en tout cas
rollin un crâne olim rlr de gagny merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france le collectif stop loi sécurité
globale appellent à manifester à nouveau
samedi prochain à paris pour déminer le
dossier explosif emmanuel macron a
déjeuné ce midi avec le président du
sénat gérard larcher et les chefs des
groupes parlementaires de la chambre
haute
l'occasion pour les sénateurs de
rappeler au président que la réécriture
de cet article leur revient de droit
après le vote à l'assemblée nationale à
l'issue du conseil des ministres ce
matin gabriel attal le porte parole du
gouvernement à son tour rejeté l'idée
d'un divorce entre la police et les
citoyens
on ne peut pas être libre sans être en
sécurité
il ya aujourd'hui des femmes et des
hommes qui se dévouent qui dédient leur
temps à protéger la sécurité de leurs
concitoyens ce sont deux policières à
nos policiers
et si les français sont attachés à leur
police républicaine
ils sont aussi exigeants avec leur
police républicaine et avec des
comportements qui lorsqu'elles sont
inacceptables doivent être identifiés et
sanctionnés
c'est le sens de ce qui a été annoncé
par le gouvernement après des faits
inacceptables qui ont été révélés ces
dernières semaines évidemment pas à
remettre en cause la liberté de la
presse ou la liberté des citoyens à être
lanceur d alerte
cette nouvelle écriture va être
présentée par la commission des lois
pour cette un délai de quinze jours qui
a été donnée par le premier ministre à
la fois pour accueillir cette
proposition de réécriture et pour
discuter sur le meilleur vecteur qui
pourra être utilisé pour la faire
adopter la proposer au parlement
je peux vous dire que le premier
ministre a chargé le ministre de
l'intérieur de lui faire des
propositions dans cet objectif qui est
de renforcer cette confiance est de
répondre à un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui ont émergé à
l'issue d'affaires qui ont été révélés
ces derniers jours et que c'est le même
horizon le même délai de quinze jours
qui a été demandé par le premier
ministre au ministre de l'intérieur
ouais la cristallisation des tensions
autour de cet arc 24 peut-elle tourner à
la crise politique et institutionnelle
également le symptôme d'un mal plus
profond de notre démocratie
place à notre décryptage avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec gérard longuet sénateur l ère de la
meuse bonsoir gérard longuet merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés jean
christophe lagarde président hu dei
député de la 5e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir jean
christophe lagarde merci d'être avec
nous alors pour calmer le jeu on l'a dit
emmanuel macron a donc déjeuner avec
gérard larcher président du sénat et les
chefs de groupes parlementaires du sénat
pour déminer donc cette politique autour
de l'article 24 les députés auraient dû
être associer davantage même si comme
l'a rappelé hier gérard larcher tête au
sénat évidemment de réécrire le texte
jean christophe lagarde écoutez on
confine au ridicule hier monsieur natale
pour parole du gouvernement disait dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale qu'
il reprendre reprocher aux oppositions
de ne pas avoir fait des propositions
on lui a fait des propositions mais
comme d'habitude arrogant et sûr de même
le gouvernement et la majorité ont dit
finalement que il avait raison et que
quoi qu'il arrive il adopté le texte tel
qu'il l'avait prévu
pire que ça une fois avoir adopté le
texte et se rendre compte qu'ils avaient
voté un texte qui non seulement
n'interdisait pas aux journalistes de
filmer ou citoyens de filmer et diffuser
mais le protéger en rien aux policiers
ils ont décidé de le réécrire et ils ont
juste oublié dans une petite chose c'est
que le sénat existait c'est à dire que
c'est aujourd'hui le sénat qui a le
texte entre les mains dans le dos
navette parlementaire et ils disent on
va réécrire le texte qu'ils attendent
déjà que le sénat travaille je leur ai
dit moi même dans l'hémicycle que ce
texte serait réécrit par de sénart parce
que c'était une évidence parce qu'il
était ni efficace ni utile qu'en réalité
ils percevaient il ne permettait de
poursuivre absolument rien donc résultat
des courses c'est entre les mains du
sénat et on nous a sortis avant d une
commission une commission c'est à dire
des gens qui te sont élus par personne
qui me rendent de comptes à personne
pour réécrire la loi
on est arrivés dans un tel pataquès
qu'il faut revenir à la sagesse
le sénat est normalement une chambre où
les patients sont moins grandes où les
enjeux politiques semblent moins grand
et par contre tous les enjeux à la fois
d' équilibre de la loi et de libertés
individuelles sont plus respectés
malheureusement qu'à l'assemblée
nationale alors précisément la
commission indépendante à laquelle vous
faites allusion aux mises en place par
le premier me sort âge aussi des
propositions sur les relations entre la
presse et les forces de sécurité tandis
que la commission des lois de
l'assemblée va réécrire d'ici quinze
jours ce fameux article 24 de la
proposition de loi sécurité ça vous
convient
gérard larcher qu'attendez-vous de cette
commission
simplement
mais non ça ne convient pas du tout je
pense que le président de la république
mais connaît profondément le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
parlementaires
la france est un état de droit président
de la république un rôle éminent
principal mais ce n'est pas lui
et ce n'est pas son gouvernement qui
votent la loi ce sont les parlementaires
nous à les députés en dernier ressort et
les sénateurs sont actuellement
consultées et en général faut savoir que
dans notre pays
60 à 70% des amendements proposés par le
sénat sont en général retenu par
l'assemblée nationale
donc nous jouons vraiment notre rôle de
modérateur et nous avons bien
l'intention de le jouer complètement et
nous n'accepterons pas ce sentiment
d'être guidé d'être encadrés par une
commission extérieure une commission
théodule qui n'aura d'autre légitimité
que d'avoir été nommé par on ne sait qui
d'ailleurs parce que entre le président
de la république et du premier ministre
on ne sait pas très bien qui a eu cette
idée lumineuse
après que l'assemblée nationale se soit
exprimée de dire 90 café l'assemblée
nationale ne compte pas et on va
réécrire nous-mêmes ce texte c'est une
tragédie française parce que nous avons
besoin en période de crise d'avoir des
institutions qu'ils soient respectés
avec la contribution de chacun il ya des
gens de droite des gens de gauche ya une
sorte de pignons toutes sortes
d'expériences
c'est aux institutions de fonctionner ce
n'est pas au président de la république
et son entourage immédiat de décider ce
que veulent les français les français
routes et des élus des parlementaires
pour cela que le président les laisse
travailler dans leurs fonctions
les sénateurs de gauche à eux aussi sont
émus de cet épisode de navettes
parlementaires qui ne grandit pas notre
démocratie selon eux je vous propose de
regarder avant de réagir le tweet du
patron des sénateurs ps patrick kader le
gouvernement est en train de perdre son
sang froid
il n'y aura plus de commission pourrait
écrire l'article 24
ce sont les groupes majoritaires qui ont
décidé de le réécrire
alors que nous sommes en pleine navette
parlementaire c'est un peu le grand
n'importe quoi sur le plan
institutionnel
c'est totalement contraire aux textes
qui régissent notre démocratie
pour la petite info patrick anr est un
proche de françois hollande qui a
lui-même invité emmanuel macron à
retirer ce texte il faut retirer ce
projet de loi de ces curieuses retirer
l'article 24 selon vous jean christophe
lagarde
ni l'un ni l'autre on a aujourd'hui un
problème
les forces de sécurité les forces de
l'ordre sont régulièrement film et est
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qui en soi est normal puisque ça
permet de savoir ce qu'il s'est passé le
problème c'est que les policiers les
gendarmes
nos fonctionnaires qui garantissent
notre sécurité sont identifiés et
attaqués dans leur vie privée lorsque
ceux ci se produit il ya donc une
solution
pardon déquilibre simple que lui d y a
proposé c'est qu'on doit concept et le
droit de diffuser deux films et une
opération de police mais que pour autant
on ne doit pas pouvoir reconnaître les
personnes qui sont dans l'action
pourquoi je dis ça parce que vous et moi
on a besoin de savoir ce qui s'est passé
pas qui a fait quoi
et ce sont les magistrats les
inspections de l'âge et la gendarmerie
les inspections de la police nationale
qui ont besoin de savoir qui donc c'est
très simple en réalité pour faire en
sorte que les médias ou les citoyens
puissent permettre de faire connaître ce
qui s'est passé notamment quand ça s'est
mal passé parce que c'est là où c'est
fusée de savoir ce qui s'est passé sans
qu'on sache l'identité des personnes
l'idée dans l'identité des personnes
elle concerne les inspections générales
elle concerne les juges cinq magistrats
ceux qui sont amenés à sanctionner mais
on n'en est plus là on n'en est plus là
l'absurdité de la décision
gouvernementale
et comme le disait gérard longuet de ce
non respect des institutions où on nous
invente des gens qui ne sont pas
parlementaires
cette fameuse commission qui ne rendent
de comptes devant personnes qui n'ont de
légitimité devant personne qui ferait la
loi à la place de ceux qui sont élus
pour ça je dis une chose saint pardon
mais ce n'est pas la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale qui va réécrire
le texte de loi c-2 sénat qu'il a
aujourd'hui entre les mains moi je fais
confiance au sénat pour trouver un
équilibre sur l'article et sur l'article
22 qui lui est gravement attentatoire
aux libertés publiques
on y reviendra j'ai l'espère parce que
l'article 24 n'empêchait pas ni les
citoyens ni les journalistes de filmer
de diffuser mais ne protège et pas de
policier il faut le réécrire et le sénat
doit le faire puisque l'assemblée la
majorité de playmobil qui ont levé la
main sur un texte
ils sont prêts à faire la même chose à
nos confrères dans quelques semaines le
sénat doit faire son boulot avec sagesse
et il doit regarder l'article 22 parce
que cet article 22
il est dangereux réellement dangereux
parce qu'aujourd'hui en l'état tel qu'il
a été voté par l'assemblée nationale et
je les dis dans les débats de
l'assemblée nationale il permet à
n'importe quel policier avec des drones
de surveiller en tout temps et en tout
lieu
tous les citoyens en dehors de leur
domicile ce qui sans aucun contrôle d'un
magistrat
j'espère pardonnez-moi jean christophe
lagarde société un sens que vous nous
dites justement parce que beaucoup
craignent ou dix en tout cas que le
sénat majoritairement à droite on le
rappelle comptent durcir ce texte avec
précisément l'article 22
auxquels vous faites allusion
l'utilisation des drones est ce qu'on
bascule dans un état de plus en plus
autoritaire gérard longuet non alors le
sénat est très attentif à la has qui
sont de la démocratie c'est à dire le
principe de liberté individuelle
nous acceptons naturellement la
discipline de la sécurité le respect de
la loi le respect de l'autorité
mais nous entendons profondément que les
pouvoirs publics n'utilisent pas leur
autorité pour viol et d'une façon
constante et sans contrôle
évidemment la liberté de chacun cette
affaire de drones et est exemplaire de
du travail bâclé dans la préparation des
textes et comme l'a dit jean christophe
lagarde de l'incapacité de ceux qui sont
au banc du gouvernement l'assemblée ou
c'est moi de comprendre que certaines
choses doivent être révisées yahia aucun
déshonneur à canton et milices talibanes
finalement vous avez raison cet aspect
je l'avais mal vu mes collaborateurs
était trop orienté professionnel pas
assez liberté quand on a un savoir faire
politique eh bien on évalue et on tire
les conséquences d'une éventuelle bévue
or cette affaire de drones est en effet
une bévue parce que au moment où on
découvre que nous sommes fichus fliquer
par par les grands réseaux sociaux qui
exploite toutes les données et il y a
une réaction européenne qui est assez
saine il
il ya des mesures comme les rg [ __ ] en
france farhi en europe qui s'efforce de
protéger la liberté
il faudrait que ce soit non
fonctionnaires qui chacun proprio motu
décide d'utiliser un drone pour savoir
ce qui se passe dans votre jardin
si vous êtes avec à votre conjoint ou
avec votre voisine par exemple si vous
faites la fête ou si au contraire vous
bricoler enfin c'est absolument
invraisemblable alors je pense que
évidemment c'est une vision excessive
mais à l'origine c'est le manque de
dialogue
le manque d'approfondissement on veut
aller vite on n'écoute personne
et on bâcle des textes et on arrive
évidemment à des déroutes législatives
parce que la france a quand même une
tradition juridique solide des et des
magistrats une magie sera publique lors
judiciaires qui sont capables de
donneurs prévu et j'ajoute parce que les
commissions dont on parle d'experts
c'est avant la loi qu'il faut les
écouter
il n'y a rien d une europe pour un
ministre a convoqué les bâtonnier des
avocats des magistrats il les écoute
avant mais quand le texte est présenté
devant le parlement
alors c'est au parlement de faire son
travail et s'il ya eu des erreurs y
compris l'article 22 mai c'est pas le
seul eh bien il faut avoir la
l'honnêteté de dire qu'on s'est trompé
ou en mal comme mal évaluer une
situation
en tout cas le oui le débat est
désormais lancée on l'a entendu hier
avec vous d'ailleurs jean christophe
lagarde
oui le sénat alors je n'ai pas fini
parce qu'on entendait jean christophe
lagarde à l'assemblée y est avancé aussi
le débat alors parmi les pistes en au
sujet de ce fameux article 24 toujours
gens m'ont un jean castex l'annoncé ce
matin l'afrique 25 du projet de loi dont
l'objectif selon le premier ministre
n'est pas éloigné de l'arctique 24 pour
être une piste d'aboutissement
ça nous conviendrait jean christophe
lagarde beaucoup d'émoi je ne me
prononce jamais avoir d'avoir un texte
sur les yeux parce que vous savez quand
on vote la loi ce qui ma responsabilité
ce qui est celle de gérard longuet de
l'assemblée du sénat
il faut regarder le texte pourquoi parce
qu'après les magistrats vont avoir à
l'interpréter et à l'appliquer et donc
la virgule elle est important dans un
texte de loi
or pardon quand on nous parle d'
intentions après ce que je viens de voir
de subir comme nous l'avons tous subi
sur l'article 24
il faut arrêter de faire des textes
d'amateurs ou salue le président de la
république disait il ya un an je crois à
ses députés
soyez fier d'être amateur moi je dis au
président de la république et limitent à
l'amateurisme
c'est à dire que quand on fait la loi et
encore plus la loi pénale celle qui nous
sanctionne quand nous faisons des fautes
on doit être sérieux et comme bien de
dire gérard longuet
il faut que ce gouvernement que ce
pouvoir accès apprennent la vertu de l'
échange du débat du dialogue parce que
moi je ne prétends pas avoir toujours
raison et parfois dans le débat
j'entends des gens qui disent des choses
intelligentes auquel je n'avais pas
pensé équipements qui me permettre de
changer mon opinion qu'est ce qui s'est
passé sur l'article de l'intercom sur
l'article 22 et des drones c'est pas les
drones qui sont en cause c'est
simplement cette espèce d'idée
permanente d'avoir toujours raison de ne
jamais se tromper
et bien moi je lance un avertissement
tous les pouvoirs qui ont cru faire ça
de droite comme de gauche
et aujourd'hui le pouvoir ma chronique
se sont enfermés dans leurs certitudes
et se sont effondrés devant les
électeurs parce que les français ne sont
pas idiots
il s'applique quant à pouvoir te bourhis
bourg et ils savent le sanctionner on a
besoin dans notre pays de débats et d
équilibre de confiance dans l'équipe des
institutions la lumière ne vient pas
l'elysée et l'obscurité n'est pas au
sénat ou à l'assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs l'assemblée nationale ils
feraient bien de laisser leurs députés
réfléchir se libérer voter est pas être
son du canon en fonction de ce qui a été
décidé par les uns et par les autres
l'article 24 n'était pas liberticide
mais il doit être écrit parce qu'il
était inefficace
l'article 22 est clairement liberticide
et il doit être réécrit par le sénat et
par l'assemblée nationale pour qu'on
permettre l'usagé des drogues mais que
ça ne se passe pas dans n'importe quelle
condition
parce que comme le dit gérard longuet ça
peut se faire n'importe quelle pression
mais c'est même pire que ce qu'il disait
avec un drôle on peut savoir dans votre
bureau
ce que vous êtes en train de lire on
peut regarder ce que vous êtes en train
d'échanger puisqu'avec la lecture
labiale on peut savoir ce que vous étiez
en train de dire on peut regarder ce que
vous faites dans votre salle de sport
dans votre véhicule dans votre jardin
non mais attendez il ya qu'en chine que
ça ne choquerait personne mais pas dans
la république française
gérard longuet le mot de la fin si je
résume la gauche veut le retrait du
texte la droite veut réécrire
l'article c'est pas un piège dans lequel
finalement est tombée
emmanuel macron cette fois de sécurité
notamment cet article 24 ce sera le mot
de la fin pour vous manque de
professionnalisme et travail solitaire
voilà c'était une conclusion
effectivement rapide merci à vous gérard
longuet merci également à vous jean
christophe lagarde président et dénis
député de la 5e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis gérard longuet
sénateur l ère de la meuse merci à tous
les deux les violences policières
concentre l'essentiel des débats ces
dernières semaines une question vient se
poser l'igpn y sont innocentes elles
systématiquement les policiers en cause
éléments de réponse avec david khalifa
enquêter sur la déontologie des forces
de l'ordre voilà le rôle principal de
l'igpn cette institution que l'on
appelle aussi la police des polices et
où je me trouve actuellement n'a pas le
pouvoir de sanctionner directement
elle mène des enquêtes et peut proposer
des sanctions ou condamnation des
enquêtes en nette augmentation depuis
ces trois dernières années notamment sur
des violences volontaires
mais la plupart n'ont pratiquement
jamais abouti à des condamnations
judiciaires
pour bien comprendre il faut d'abord se
concentrer sur deux termes
les enquêtes ouvertes sont à la fois
administrative et judiciaire
le volet administratif se concentre
uniquement sur le fonctionnement interne
de la police
la procédure peut aboutir à des
sanctions disciplinaires pour ce qui est
du volet judiciaire les procédures
peuvent conduire à des peines prévues
par le code pénal
si je suis là pour condamner fermement
tous les policiers qui ne respectent pas
la déontologie
je voudrais dire tout mon soutien
profond à l'immense majorité des
chansons qui risquent leur vie pour nous
condamner fermement tous les mauvais
policiers tout en réitérant son soutien
aux forces de l'ordre le ministre de
l'intérieur a voulu jeter un pavé en
eaux troubles
en parlant de pavés ça me rappelle
quelque chose
des images qui ont choqué et surtout cet
homme est devenu le premier policier
être condamné pour des violences
volontaires depuis le début du mouvement
des gilet jaune
deux mois de prison avec sursis mais
elle pourra toujours exercé sa fonction
on l'espère avec 100 au monde dans les
mains et cette procédure fait partie des
1460 enquêtes judiciaires ouvertes en
2010 9 868 d'entre elles portaient sur
des violences volontaires par des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
83 seulement abouti à des condamnations
judiciaires de ce type
un chiffre qui parle de lui-même et les
statistiques en général confirme la
rareté des poursuites judiciaires dans
les affaires de violences policières
exemple plus précis de ses statistiques
avec ce rapport de l' ong chrétienne à 4
publié en 2016 sur 89 situation a légué
de violences policières survenues en
france entre 2005 et 2015
celles dans lesquelles la justice
s'était prononcé au moment de la
rédaction de ce rapport s'était
majoritairement soldées par des
non-lieux
on relève un manque criant de
transparence sur les chiffres de ce
rapport le taux de poursuite des
policiers plus faible que pour le reste
de la population
alors comment expliquer tout simplement
car la preuve est difficile à apporter
la plupart des enquêtes sont classées
sans suite car l'infraction principale
est insuffisamment caractérisée ça ne
veut pas dire que les faits ne se sont
pas produits mais qu'il n'existe pas de
preuves suffisantes pour obtenir une
condamnation si des certificats médicaux
et des enregistrements vidéos sont
fournis dans certaines procédures les
témoins ne se manifeste en général pas
beaucoup
pour l'opposition c'est avant tout un
problème structurel d'une
interdépendance entre police et
politique ainsi qu'une démarche assumée
voire encouragée par la hiérarchie le
gouvernement depuis le mouvement des
ligier jeunes
c'est qu'il tient par la police et
quelque part la police le tien michel
dont la tête quand même quand on la voit
c'est stupéfiant le gars sait même pas
un chaos qui s'est pris sur un terrain
sur un ring quoi ce ne sont pas des
faits anecdotiques qui peuvent juste ce
traité pas on suspend les trois
policiers s'ils se sont sentis autorisés
à faire ça c'est parce que ils ont une
autorisation faire depuis maintenant
deux ans un problème qui fait de plus en
plus de bruit dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale
prendre ses responsabilités et se
montrait intraitable envers les forces
de l'ordre prises en défaut et voilà
l'objectif affiché de gérald darmanin
mais les chiffres eux ne sont pas de cet
avis et la vidéo du passage à tabac à
paris du producteur de musique noire
michel éclair a choqué au delà des
frontières françaises la presse
internationale s'inquiète d'une dérive
vers la répression certains médias
étrangers font même le parallèle avec la
mort de john floyd aux états unis
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec météo
gisèle berti rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias bonsoir météo les aides versées
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur un
écran ce dans ce clip on a vu voilà
plein de deux pays différents tout cas
leur presse réagir mais pas l'italie que
tu es ton chez vous bonsoir je peux dire
qu'un l'italie surtout la presse de
gauche a titré sur cette agression sur
cette action de la police en soulignant
le caractère raciste pour le reste
honnêtement la presse italienne n'a pas
donné trop de convenir d'importance à
cet événement plutôt à la manifestation
ils ont parlé plus tôt de la
manifestation contre l'article 24 de la
loi sur la sécurité mais disons que
c'était cet épisode a été surtout
stigmatisé par la presse de gauche
justement y at il une forme pas
d'amalgamé une confusion entre toutes
ces violences policières présumées ou
non l'arctique 24 cette affaire est
clair est-ce qu'un mélange qui se fait
justement selon vous dans les médias
étrangers
oui parce que déjà d'une part on ne
comprend pas exactement la réalité
française de l'autre côté on lit
l'actualité française avec des lunettes
qui sont celles de son propre pays
donc ce qui concerne les médias
américains je suis pas un expert mais
les titres que je publiera c'était été
un peu comme
une façon pour dire attention il ya
effectivement eu un phénomène blake
l'armée thèse qui va éclater en france
aussi
or les deux situations sont complètement
différent dans l'essence que le
blacklight med s'installent sur des
années des décennies de comment dire des
tensions raciales aux états unis là où
il y avait encore il ya quelques années
et dans certains états des lois qui
était effectivement en ch'ti l'apartheid
on peut dire quand ça en france ce n'est
pas du tout le cas
et d'ailleurs il n'ya pas comment dire
les autorités d'aider des
administrations locales qui promet pour
certaines comment dire un comportement
raciste ou discriminatoire vis-à-vis
d'une partie de la population
donc je pense que sur tous les médias
américains ont fait un peu une bonne
guerre entre guillemets parce que on
avait accusé aussi justement là les
états unis d'avoir de toutes façons de
problème avec la violence qui sont en
tout cas
assez clair par exemple aussi la
diffusion des armes à feu qui est légal
aux états unis et qui est considéré
quelque chose d'incompréhensible de
cette côté de l'océan parler du
mouvement blake les demandeurs justement
à bruxelles le soir évoque une fr
georgia floyd à la française qu'on peut
faire ce parallèle clairement selon vous
décidément non un nom ou ceux qui le
font sont enterrés à jeter de l'huile
sur le feu ils ont des intérêts
politiques sans doute parce qu'on a vu
les scream gauche et une partie de la
gauche française et aussi d'autres pays
européenne investir 7 cet espace pour
condamner toute forme de d'autorité non
seulement d'autoritarisme qui serait
peut être compréhensible à 10 ans une
condamnation de l'autoritarisme mais
toute forme d'autorité et puis ce qui
concerne cet événement je pense que il
manque qu'il nous manque beaucoup
d'éléments aussi pour considérer la
situation bien sûr cette agression a été
très violente est absolument à condamner
mais certains observateurs ont quand
même rappeler que on n'a pas vu toute la
scène on n'a pas eu toutes les
informations comme d'ailleurs pour
d'autres faits qui sont un peu un
similaire à celui ci alors la presse dit
volontiers pays des droits de l'homme
quand elle évoque la france cela
égratine peut-être plus encore davantage
l'image du président macron l étranger
je pense qu'à l'étranger on considère la
france comme un pays qui pourrait
jouir disons des cdc liberté à 100% et
laisser lutte qui qui qui dit qui sont à
la base de son histoire au moins depuis
300 ans mais peu importe en dire plus
mais on le fait pas parce que il ya
effectivement cette verticalité du
pouvoir qui s'est accentuée quand on a
abandonné le septennat et canton à
synchroniser les élections législatives
avec celle un présidentielle dans la
même année
donc on voit que d'un côté on pourrait
imaginer que le précédent le français du
moment donc pas seulement emmanuel
macron est tout puissant mais réalité il
est aussi comment dire un paratonnerre
parce qu' il ne peut pas conduire donner
la responsabilité a aussi à d'autres
institutions de décider ou mieux vous
pour mieux dire et pourrait le faire
mais ne le fait pas parce que c'est très
pratique après d'avoir un parlement qui
vote selon les ordres du gouvernement
en tout cas emmanuel macron avait déjà
accusé il ya pas si longtemps la presse
anglo saxonne de son traitement sur la
question notamment de de l'islam c'est
un nouveau grand malentendu entre
emmanuel macron et la presse notamment
anglo saxonnes
ça dépend parce que parfois on voit que
la presse anglo saxonne donne beaucoup
d'espacé à emmanuel macron mais il faut
dire aussi que la presse anglo saxonne
et est en général encore une fois la
presse surtout de tendance de gauche al
attiyah comment dire à une
prédisposition pour considérer tout de
suite tout ce qui est mesure d'autorité
pour résoudre une série des problèmes
qu'en france on s'appelle par exemple
terrorisme islamiste djihadisme et
d'autres qu'on dirait crise sociale
il les considère tout de suite comme un
acte raciste
or loin honnêtement j'ai entendu aussi
des observateurs qui effectivement avait
marqué que ces policiers qui ont été
tout de suite arrêté est en tout cas ils
ont commencé à être jugé par la justice
justement mais ils n'ont pas eu droit au
même traitement que certains
une criminelle en compte ils ont commis
leur premier crime en essence que on les
a laissés est comment dire en liberté on
les a laissés faire encore des dégâts
alors que c'est policiers étaient à leur
premier la première haie mais en
fractions je pense qu'il y a eu un peu
une légèreté qui a risqué de des données
la police la partie saine de la police
en pâture à ceux qui voulaient
instrumentaliser son travail sans eux
sans se rappeler que la police risque
beaucoup dans ce pays parce qu'on se
rappelle qu'il ya eu deux terroristes et
ils sont même après chais des policiers
ils les ont tués devant leurs enfants
donc on peut pas dire que c'est tout
blanc ou tout noir mais qu'on dirait il
faut toujours se rappeler que cette
façon de juger a priori et qui est
amplifié aussi par les réseaux sociaux
et que donc on perd un peu le sang froid
merci beaucoup matteo ogm berti
rédacteur en chef de putsch médias
d'avoir été avec nous aux états unis à
présent donald trump évoque ouvertement
une candidature en 2024 le président
sortant américain fait allusion à la
possibilité d'être à nouveau candidat à
un second mandat lors d'une fête de noël
à la maison blanche hier soir en
attendant joe biden lui a été déclaré
vainqueur dans tous les états disputés
l'actuel ministre de la justice je cite
n'a pas vu de fraude électorale massive
susceptibles de changer le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle déclaration
hier de bilbao pourtant fidèle de la
garde rapprochée à de trump écouté il y
a eu des allégations de fraude
systématique selon lesquelles des
machines auraient été programmé pour
fausser les résultats des élections
à ce stade nous n'avons pas vu de fraude
à une échelle susceptibles de changer le
résultat de l'élection
pour en parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir sur deux
blanchemaison plat pas de faute
pardon je n'y arrivais pas de fraudes
électorales selon le ministre de la
justice pourtant qu existe toujours
deux thèses sur le résultat de ce
scrutin
oui c'est très intéressant c'est en
effet un peu la lutte de l'état de droit
contre contre l'état de fait et william
bach qui après tout est le le ministre
de la justice l'attorney général des
états-unis a bien compris que tout les
tous les recours qui avaient été formés
par l équipe d avocats de trump et bien
été rejetée les uns après les autres et
ne produisait aucun résultat donc il en
a tiré les conséquences et en effet a
dit que en l'état et bien il n'y avait
pas de preuves de fraudes de nature à
renverser le résultat de l'élection
un exemple celui de l'état de l'arizona
où toute l'administration appartient au
parti républicain
que ce soit le gouverneur que ce soit le
chef de l'administration de l'état que
ce soit le procureur que ce soit le chef
de la cour suprême locale de l'état de
l'arizona et bien tous ont également
constaté que et confirmé que ce résultat
joe biden l'avait emporté en arizona
alors ils ont eu droit évidemment à des
remarques peu amènes de la part du
président est d'ailleurs monsieur
william bureau si puisque williams bar à
le président trump la fox news je crois
a dit qu' il avait disparu et que pour
lui dans le fond il n'existait plus
alors dans le fond on peut dire que que
le président a perdu sur le plan
juridique
ces recours au niveau de la
certification dans chaque état
maintenant on passe à l'étape suivante
celle du 14 décembre
quand lorsque les grands électeurs vont
voter c'est à dire que chaque grand rêve
et de grands électeurs dans l'état
auquel il appartient votera pour le
président que pour le candidat qui a eu
la majorité dans son état et je pense
que là aussi le droit l'emportera et que
les institutions américaines sont
suffisamment solides pour que le droit
l'emportent et il n'y a pas de grandes
surprises à attendre alors objectif
manifestement présidentielle bis
pour donald trump oui et puis des
objectifs intermédiaires par exemple de
pouvoir exercer tous aux pouvoirs de
président des états unis qui est un
pouvoir considérable jusqu'au jusqu'à à
la fin de sam de son mandat c'est à dire
jusqu'au 20 janvier et jusqu'au 20
janvier il veut pouvoir nommer des gens
dans l'administration américaine pouvoir
également accordé des grâces à des gens
qui auront été condamné comme c'est en
effet le droit du président des états
unis
et puis peut-être prendre aussi les
mesures peut-être même des mesures qui
touchent à la guerre et à la paix
puisqu'on sait qu il y a quelques jours
il avait demandé à ses conseillers à son
état major
s'il était envisageable de bombarder un
objectif particulier un objectif duclair
en iront ils en avaient été dissuadées
mais en effet il joue sur ce registre et
ils compliquent en faisant cela la
transition de joe biden et de son équipe
il leur complique singulièrement les
choses et peut-être en créant des choses
tout à fait
irrémédiable alors maintenant il va y
avoir une deuxième de ce théâtre de
batailles c'est celui de congrès puisque
il va y avoir une élection le 5 janvier
en géorgie et que actuellement
l'équilibré du congrès c'est 48
démocrate et 50 républicain donc à
supposer que les deux sièges à pourvoir
en géorgie soit emportée par les
démocrates
on aurait 50 50 et dans ce cas c'est la
présidence du sénat qui fait la
différence
on sait qu aux etats unis le sénat est
présidé par la vice présidence donc de
de la fédération ce sera donc camélat à
risque et à ce moment-là fera la
différence
et dans cette hypothèse évidemment ce
serait très important pour joe biden car
il pourrait passer ses lois sans être
bloqué par un parent sénat hostile
l'enjeu est important et c'est pourquoi
trump à se battre et puis se bat aussi
naturellement pour son avenir personnel
vous l'avait dit pour sa candidature
probablement en 2024
claude rapidement quelles sont les
conséquences de cette situation actuelle
les conséquences sont multiples comme je
les dis l'équipe de transition ne peut
pas travailler normalement et tout le
paysage politique est en réalité
perturbé par cette contestation assez
radical donc aussi bien aux états unis
qu'à l'étranger on est dans une période
d'incertitude qui va durer plus d'un
mois et demi c'est très long et beaucoup
de choses peuvent arriver comme le dit
d'ailleurs monsieur trump pendant ces
six ou sept semaines
je crois que en effet le président entre
un peu quittera normalement la maison
blanche
le 19 ou le 20 janvier mais je ne suis
pas du tout certain qu'il assiste à la
cérémonie d'inauguration du nouveau
président est en effet il va jouer dur
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au bout jusqu'au 20
janvier
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse complète
on y ferait luttes internes et pressions
politiques vont bon train le parlement a
voté une première fois pour la
dissolution du gouvernement d'union de
benyamin nétanyahou et de benny ganz
ce dernier très critiques ces dernières
semaines envers son partenaire premier
ministre état hébreu plongé dans
l'incertitude politique avec une
pandémie de kobe 19 des plus
douloureuses également walid bennani
c'est un vote qui pourrait changer le
futur de la politique israélienne
[Musique]
voici les résultats du vote de la motion
pour une dissolution de la 23ème knesset
61 sont favorables et 54 contre
j'annonce que la motion a été adoptée en
lecture préliminaire
le gouvernement d'union de benyamin
nétanyahou et de benny gantz en sursis
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire et
économique
une motion votée appuyé et ce par benny
gantz dès mardi soir un vote
préliminaire qui doit être suivie de
trois autres pour que la dissolution de
la knesset soit prononcée le ministre de
la défense adversaire politique du
premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou a
accusé son partenaire de faire passer
ses intérêts personnels devant ceux du
pays
après trois élections législatives
disputer les deux hommes avaient accepté
en mars dernier d'unir leurs forces avec
une rotation de 18 mois au poste de chef
de gouvernement
l'année en angleterre par d'autres
netanyahu a promis l'unité il l'a promis
netanyahu s'est engagé à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas d'entourloupe il s'est engagé
netanyahu a promis une gestion
responsable de la crise du coronavirus
il l'a promis
netanyahu ne met pas en oeuvre cette
promesse et c'est le public qui en
paient le prix
netanyahu ne m'a pas menti il vous a
menti
l'arrêt mushi caire des paroles qui font
écho derniers désaccords sur les budgets
et 2020 et 2021 qui n'ont toujours pas
été adoptées sans accord d'ici le 23
décembre le parlement israélien se
dissoudra de lui même et des nouvelles
élections législatives seront convoqués
trois mois plus tard en mars 2021
benyamin nétanyahou jours et il alors la
montre avec l'espoir notamment d'un
redressement économique l'an prochain et
l'apparition d'un vaccin face à une
partie de la population israélienne en
colère
je crois que c'est
[Musique]
mis sous pression par benny gantz le
premier ministre a pourtant prôné
l'apaisement sur twitter juste avant le
vote du parlement
et même si le parti bleu et blanc de
benny ganz dans ce gouvernement à former
un gouvernement dans un gouvernement
s'est opposé à nous tout le temps à
violer les accords de coalition je leur
dis de tout mettre de côté béni ce qu'il
faut faire maintenant c'est un
changement de cap politique pour les
citoyens de l'état d'israël c'est ce
qu'il faut faire maintenant et je vous
le demande
faites le et netanyahu fera été accusés
de fraude d'abus de confiance et
d'acceptation de pau devant dans une
série de scandales des proches du
premier ministre visé également dans une
affaire de corruption d'achat de
sous-marins à un constructeur allemand
une enquête est en cours le futur procès
pourrait rabattre certaines cartes
même si le likoud parti politique de
benyamin netanyahou reste toujours
numéro un dont les sondages restent avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la stratégie vaccinale de
la france elle sera détaillé demain par
jean castets le pays qu'à précommander
de quoi vacciner 100 millions de
personnes précise le premier ministre
outre la logistique le gouvernement sera
vraisemblablement confronté à un défi de
taille convaincre les français
[Musique]
et
que s'est il passé entre juillet dernier
la mi novembre pour que la hongrie puis
la pologne
tous deux sont tenues un par la slovénie
décident d'imposer leur veto au plan de
relance de l'union européenne les
européens ont décidé de mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle une clause de
conditionnalité c'est à dire ils
conditionnent ce versement au respect de
certaines mesures de l'état de droit
c'est l'europe qui dit nous allons
décider pour vous et nous allons nous
immiscer on ne va avoir une juridiction
en fait plus haute que les vôtres qui
sont anti européen de toulon dirt c'est
bien connu et donc ils sont dans une
posture aussi je pense que ils vont très
rapidement cédé sur ces points là parce
qu'ils ont besoin de cet argent pour
qu'il dise non alors que c'est les
principaux bénéficiaires de ce plan de
relance
ça peut bien dire qu'il ya un vrai souci
[Musique]
le mont choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être que ce qui
va rester c'est que les films qui seront
de plus en plus fait pour le cinéma et
pas sur les grands réseaux resteront des
objets artistiques sitting godard qui
disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux tout est dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une famille qui a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique ne peut pas
dans notre politique internationale il
est bien évident qu'il faut pas créer
les conditions à nouveau une terre de
jihad et de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense
tout au long des années l'alliance
atlantique s'est investi dans des
guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
traduit la situation s'est aggravée avec
le début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet et 10 juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus 10 livres haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne que c'est
à l'europe d'être en capacité d'assumer
la responsabilité de sa propre sécurité
et d'agir de manière autonome quand
c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu des
divergences avec quelle europe pourront
nous le faire
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes coups
politiques n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
compte l on soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche veut extrêmement
sujet dès le matin la société fonctionne
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview il n'y a pas
une façon plus pauvres de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
qu'un autre le peuple c'était une
volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que des gants dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dit nous plaît gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminés au coin de
chaque semaine je pense que le système
des chu est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les siens jurant racontines notre
des plaintes le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour répètent à
la place du gouvernement français en ce
moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
ont testé 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur pour décoincer jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
un bon soir 21h heure française merci
nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
émission tout de suite voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 2 décembre
après six mois d'auditions la commission
d' enquête parlementaire de l'assemblée
rend son verdict sur la gestion de la
crise du coc vide les députés pointent
un pilotage défaillant et accable le
gouvernement demain le premier ministre
détaillera la stratégie vaccinale
française alors que la grande bretagne
vient de donner son autorisation en
vaccins pfizer biotech et que vladimir
poutine en russie demande de députés de
débuter la vaccination de masse dès la
fin de la semaine prochaine au chevet du
liban emmanuel macron réitère ses
exigences de réforme à l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle conférence des d'humanitaire en
visio ce soir initiée par paris en lien
avec les nations unies
il s'agit de mobiliser des fonds pour un
pays dévasté par l'explosion du 4 août
et éviter l'effondrement de l'économie
nationale
le pays du cèdre déjà confronté à une
grave crise crise politique
audition aujourd'hui de roanne wade au
par la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat le président de
l'assemblée nationale du venezuela appel
au boycott des élections législatives
dimanche dans son pays
des élections qu'il juge frauduleuse et
en appellent à l'europe
c'était le premier pays à approuver un
vaccin ce sera l'un des tout premiers
pays au monde a entamé sa campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vite 19 la
russie un vaccin au nom de spoutnik v
gratuit pour tous les citoyens russes et
non obligatoire et que je sais que plus
de deux millions de doses ont déjà été
fabriquées où seront fabriquées dans les
jours à venir et on atteindra ce niveau
la production du premier vaccin
enregistrés contre le coronavirus dans
le monde
spoutnik v spoutnik les nîmois nous
permet de lancer une campagne de
vaccination
même si ce n'est pas une vaccination de
masse et une vaccination d'envergure
comme prévu il s'agit tout d'abord de
deux groupes à risque les médecins et
des enseignants
si vous estimez que nous sommes sur le
point de prendre cette mesure
je vous demande d'organiser le travail
de manière à commencer cette vaccination
d'envergure dès la fin de la semaine
prochaine quand c'est serré chine il ya
les mots j'ai pu stopper le match en
angleterre ce sera le vexin pfizer
bintec qui sera commercialisée feu vert
du chef du gouvernement aujourd'hui et
40 millions de doses ont déjà été
commandés environ 100000 devrait
arrivé la semaine prochaine hélène
masquelier une première mondiale est une
nouvelle étape dans la lutte contre la
pandémie
le vaccin développé par les laboratoires
américains et allemands pfizer et
biotech est le premier à être
officiellement approuvé le pdg du
laboratoire américain jubile et a salué
ce matin un moment historique tandis que
les britanniques de leur côté crie
victoire
le gouvernement a accepté aujourd'hui la
recommandation de l'agencé indépendante
de réglementation des médicaments et des
produits de santé d'approuver
l'utilisation du vaccin contre le coc
vite 19 de files heures biotech
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson a salué sur les réseaux sociaux
une nouvelle fantastique seulement dix
mois après le début de son élaboration
c'est le vaccin le plus rapide jamais
conçu pour passer du concept à la
réalité des étapes qui s'étale
normalement sur une décennie
le royaume uni a déjà commandé 40
millions de doses suffisamment pour
vacciner 20 millions de personnes
la campagne est donc imminente dans le
pays c'est une fantastique nouvelle que
lé agences de réglementation des
médicaments et des produits de santé
organismes de réglementation clairement
indépendant est autorisée cliniquement
le vaccin pour un déploiement ultérieur
le système national de santé est prête à
y parvenir donc dès le début de la
semaine prochaine nous entamerons le
plan de vaccination de la population
contre le colis de 19 dans ce pays le
vaccin d'une efficacité de 95 % selon
pfizer et bio ntech sera d'abord inoculé
aux personnes prioritaires
ainsi les résidents des maisons de
retraite le personnel soignant et les
plus vulnérables devraient être les
premiers à en bénéficier dès la semaine
prochaine et une campagne de vaccination
plutôt bien accueilli par les londoniens
à côté
cette campagne de vaccination est une
très bonne nouvelle car il faut faire au
plus vite
certains sont inquiets face à une
vaccination aussi rapide mais c'est
surtout nécessaire pour les maisons de
retraite et les personnes âgées qui sont
bloquées chez elles depuis des mois et
des mois
c'est une bonne nouvelle j'espère que
les gens vont se faire vacciner malgré
leurs inquiétudes
je pense que c'est un exploit
extraordinaire
c'est un exploit extraordinaire merci à
tous les scientifiques ou chercheurs
je ne connais personne qui travaille
dans la recherche mais ils font un
travail formidable
il travaille si dur et ils vont sauver
des vies je pense qu'ils ont investi
beaucoup d'argent dans ce projet d'après
ce que j'ai lu dans les médias vu à la
télévision
c'est une campagne très sérieuse menée
par de nombreux scientifiques donc j'ai
confiance
oui et chez nous dans l'hexagone la
campagne de vaccination sera progressive
elle devrait débuter dès le début de
l'année prochaine
invité chez nos confrères de bfm tv se
met un jean qu'un sexe a confirmé une
pré commande de 100 millions de doses
le premier ministre qui doit détailler
demain la stratégie gouvernementale lors
du point presse hebdomadaire et les
défis autour de ce vaccin sont donc
multiples on l'aura compris mais le plus
dur sera peut-être de convaincre le plus
de monde possible de se faire vacciner
pour mettre fin à l'épidémie alors
comment rassurer et convaincre notamment
les français très sceptique place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
mais mes gars ban chefs de service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bon soir bruno mais garbade merci
d'être avec nous rachid digoit
infirmiers président du collectif inter
blocs dont soir à vous aussi de nîmes il
est co président de la fédération des
syndicats de pharmaciens de
loire-atlantique et pharmaciens qui
auront peut-être un grand rôle à jouer
dans cette campagne de vaccination
bonsoir denis millet merci d'être avec
nous les britanniques qui ont dit oui à
ce vaccin le vaccin de pfizer et bio
ntech il sera disponible dès la semaine
prochaine au royaume uni je vous propose
avant de réagir d'écouter le tweet de
boris johnson c'est fantastique que la
mhra est officiellement autorisé fighter
biotech contre le coc vide 19 le vaccin
commencera à être disponible dans tout
le royaume uni à partir de la semaine
prochaine
c'est la protection des vaccins qui nous
permettra enfin de compte de reprendre
nos vies et de relancer l'économie
évidemment les anglais qui se
réjouissent bruno m'égare ban
ils ont une raison justement ces anglais
de se réjouir ou on va quand même un peu
trop vite selon vous en angleterre parce
que beaucoup le penserait ici en france
non je crois ils ont tout à fait raison
effectivement la recherche médicale
un permis très rapidement de mettre au
point un vaccin efficace et avec une un
niveau de sécurité suffisant pour que
les autorités sanitaires autorise sa
mise sur le marché
il faut savoir cette technologie tout à
fait révolutionnaire permet dominé au
plus proche l'infection naturelle avec
une stimulation de l'immunité non
seulement immoral mais également
cellulaire et probablement permettra une
bonne immunisation en tout cas dans les
meilleures conditions
donc évidemment il faut se réjouir car
malheureusement en l'absence de
vaccination
il faudra poursuivre les mesures
barrières et surtout au moment de rebond
remettre en place des confinement ce qui
est extrêmement néfaste pour la société
et la vie économique alors beaucoup de
réjouissance du côté de l'angleterre
mais beaucoup de doute encore on le sait
en france a notamment il ya beaucoup de
questions autour des vaccins en général
on va essayer d'y répondre avec nous
dans quelques instants
mais en tout cas les autorités
sanitaires britanniques elles se veulent
très rassurante je vous propose
justement d'écouter le docteur john
wayne
c'est la patronne de ce fameux
régulateur médicale britannique que
citer boris johnson la recommandation de
la mhr à a été atteinte à la suite d'un
examen extrêmement approfondie et
scientifiquement rigoureux de toutes les
preuves de la sécurité de l'efficacité
et de la qualité du vaccin fighter bio
ntech le gouvernement britannique a
maintenant accepté cet avis et a pris la
décision d'approuver il usage du vaccin
avec certaines conditions pour les
adultes âgés de 16 ans et plus alors
c'est vrai denis mines et qu'on entend
souvent les français relevé mollahs tout
cela y aller très vite qu'on a créé un
vaccin en un temps record que les études
scientifiques ne sont pas encore
complètement complète les britanniques
sont moins méfiants que les français
c'est ça la leçon
alors peut-être que l'administration
vont plus vite que les autres
le vaccin sera validée en france par le
même système chez nous c'est l' agence
du médicament qui va faire ça je pense
qu'on pourra voir complètement confiance
à partir moi c'est validé avec des
études l'instant on ne dispose pas sur
le terrain mais une fois que ces études
auront été bien bien vérifié par par
l'ânesse aime ça pourrait sortir sur le
marché sans sans inconvénients
donc on est en toute sérénité assez
cocasse que vous nous dites parce que
c'est vrai que le ministre britannique
de la santé s'est fait un peu taper sur
les doigts par certains aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a assuré que c'était le
break site 1 qui avait permis au royaume
uni d'être le premier pays occidental à
autoriser un vaccin parce qu'il n'avait
pas le poids de l'administration vous
bruno m'égare ban c'est quelque chose
que vous qu'on connait on est un petit
peu lent d'un point de vue administratif
c'est vrai que les autorisations sont
souvent voilà notamment de l'eau de la
haute autorité sont souvent longues à
donner mais il faut des prudence tout de
même nom oui tout à fait vous avez
raison effectivement il faut bien
examiner le dossier dans tous ses
détails
même si nous médecins n'avons pas accès
pour le moment donné il faut également
s'entourer des bonnes conditions pour
pouvoir vacciner la population car comme
vous le savez évidemment il y à des
conditions techniques assez exigeante
pour ce vaccin qui doit être conservé et
transporté à moins 70 degrés et donc il
faut bien sûr des réfrigérateurs le
permettant il faut donc tout organisé
pour que les choses se passent dans la
sérénité et donc effectivement
actuellement la circulation du virus
diminue on va pouvoir passer des fêtes
très tranquillement mais à la sortie et
donc au début de l'année 2000 21
il faudra rapidement commencé ses
vaccinations notamment par les personnes
à risque c'est-à-dire les personnes les
plus âgées dans les épaules alors
effectivement le point presse nous en
dira plus demain sur cette stratégie
française
une chose est sûre on vient de le dire
vaccin disponible au royaume uni en
russie également à vladmir poutine
demande le début des vaccinations à
grande échelle la semaine prochaine
rachid digoit vous avez le sentiment
qu'on on commence à être finalement en
retard comme on l'a été pour les masques
et les tests on rappelle ce rapport les
commissions de l'assemblée très dur pour
le gouvernement dans la gestion de la
crise qu vide est ce que vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on semble
suivre le même chemin concernant les
vaccins chemin je sais pas puisque il ya
beaucoup de prudence par rapport à ce
vaccin mais c'est sûr que là les
résultats de la commission d enquête et
ben rhodes a tu vraiment tout ce que les
soignants
on dit depuis des mois toutes les
failles administratif toutes les failles
de la gouvernance et aujourd'hui je
crois que le plus gros pari s'avère
justement au gouvernement de de
convaincre tous toute la population
d'aller se faire vacciner parce qu'ils
ont quand même il ya eu une gestion de
crise qui était quand même assez
catastrophique
une première vague où il ya eu très peu
de choses de gérer la deuxième vague on
l'a pris de plein fouet il n'y a pas eu
non plus beaucoup de choses de en amont
de gérer donc ça va être très compliqué
je pense pour eux de convaincre
aujourd'hui
alors pour être très clair on va tenter
d'y voir plus clair avec vous il ya six
vaccins pré commandé par l'union
européenne on va les regarder s'afficher
sur notre écran trois vaccins dits
modernes fabriqués à base d'arn messager
trois autres dits classiques le mec le
vexin files r on voit ces
caractéristiques en bas à gauche il se
conserve
vous l'avez dit un docteur tout à
l'heure à moins 70 degrés impossible en
pharmacie comment du coup effectué sa
distribution à grande échelle que ce
soit en grande bretagne mais aussi en
france denis millet alors la partie qui
doit être conservé à blois - 110
dégraisser d'une parts et la majorité du
temps après ce qu'on a entendu dire
c'est que pour les derniers instants il
pourra rester quelques jours dans un
frigo normal il y aura plusieurs phases
donc la phase à moins de 110 de grèce va
être réservé à des structures très
spécialisés parce que très peu de
personnes disposent de matériel
nécessaire par contre les quelques les
quelques derniers jours pour être
assurés effectivement par le relais
classique de nos grossistes qui vont
très très vite et des pharmacies
éventuellement après pour arriver chez
les médecins et les infirmiers qui le
feront quand quand ça sera disponible en
ville je pense que la première structure
sera faite notamment pour les ehpad et
les ehpad france 3 seront approvisionnés
directement par un circuit n'était pas
la peine de multiplier les les étapes
est ce que le gouvernement vous a déjà
sollicité en tant que pharmacien dans
l'éventuel rôle et dans le rôle tout
court que vous aurez à jouer dans cette
campagne de vaccination alors le
gouvernement a directement puisque enfin
la chaîne notamment puisqu'on a on a
émis des notre avis sur les premières
recommandations de la chaise maintenant
des mêmes avant la sortie du rapport
voilà on a été puis on est un tueur en
contact soit et le ministère vont avec
telle assurance maladie pour savoir pour
dire dans quelle mesure nous serons
impliqués soit pour l'acheminement et
probablement aussi des cas passera pour
un plus grand nombre pour pour la
vaccination elle même alors qui pourra
se faire vacciner quand c'est la grande
question que tous les français se posent
aux questions que ça a commencé à livrer
de plus en plus de détails ça devrait
annoncer demain quand je vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre nous avons
pré commandé par le système européen de
quoi vacciner 100 millions de personnes
encore faudrait-il et là il faut tout
six mètres que le plus possible de
français acceptent de se faire vacciner
c'est un vrai sujet il allait faire
accepter la vaccination français
finalement au bruno m'égare ban c'est ce
qui va être le plus dur vous le craignez
vous aussi alors je le crains pas parce
que je crois que de les les gens sont
raisonnables
donc effectivement ils vont peut-être un
peu attendre mais très rapidement ils
vont bien voir que ce vaccin était très
bien su qu'il n'y a pas de risque à se
faire vacciner par contre il n'y a que
des avantages pour être protégés et pour
pouvoir reprendre une vie normale et
donc même si très probablement il y a
encore un peu de méfiance
rapidement je crois qu'elle va passer et
puis les personnes vont se faire
vacciner
ce d'autant plus que très probablement
dans un certain nombre de pays pour
pouvoir voyager pour pouvoir participer
à certaines activités
peut-être même sur certains lieux de
travail la vaccination sera exigé donc
en fait tout le monde n'aura d'intérêt
qu'à se faire vacciner
mais est ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
dans ces cas là la rendre tout de suite
obligatoire ça va pas compliquer encore
plus quelque chose elle est retardée
d'une certaine manière ne pas avoir
rendu obligatoire cette vaccination
selon vous toujours bruno mega man
non je crois pas parce que le rendent
obligatoire d'emblée aurait
immédiatement attiré la méfiance et
vêtements se serait posé la question
pourquoi rendre obligatoire un vaccin
notamment effectivement pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas à risque
individuellement de faire une forme
grave à nouveau ça aurait été
extrêmement utiles
si c'était pour protéger chacun d'entre
nous mais là en fait on se fait vacciner
dans l'idée bien sûr de ralentir la
circulation du virus voire de l'empêcher
totalement pour protéger les autres et
donc c'est vrai que le rendre
obligatoire d'emblée on était un peu
difficile je crois qu'il faut plutôt
convaincre faire de la pédagogie est
très probablement la population va
adhérer très rapidement même si bien sûr
on n'atteindra probablement pas 100 % de
personnes maxi des mais le fait de se
rapprocher de 60% permettra d'espérer un
ralentissement important de la
circulation du virus est une reprise de
la vie normale des des prochains est
denis millet quand on voit la défiance
en cette défiance scepticisme vous
rejoignez bruno mais garbani il faut de
la pédagogie sa pasqua par le
gouvernement c'est le rôle du
gouvernement mais aussi vous les
médecins d'aller sur les plateaux de
télévision les médias
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
c'est d'urgence d'urgence ça va être de
convaincre je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le docteur ben gardane va falloir
convaincre que ce vaccin il est efficace
il est sûr et il va falloir aussi
expliquer vraiment aux gens que
l'intérêt de se faire vacciner c'est pas
que pour soi mais c'est pour les autres
parce qu'on a des parents en ehpad qu'on
a envie d'aller les voir parce qu'on a
des enfants petits qui sont peuvent être
fragiles parce que on a de la famille ou
à des amis parce qu'on veut participer
retournez voir des concerts retourner
aussi des bars tout retourné vivre et
que c'est c'est la massivité c'est à
dire le nombre de gens qui seront
vaccinés qui permettra de re libérer un
petit peu nous renouard libérer tous il
faut tout le monde participe faut pas
attendre que soient les autres qu'ils le
fassent au tous participé à ça alors
trois chiffres intéressants vous montrer
pour alimenter ce débat ceux de la
campagne de vaccination 2018 2000
19 35 % des soignants dans les
établissements de santé étaient vaccinés
32% dans les ehpad dont seulement 27 %
de personnel soignant qui se font
vacciner ans rachid digoit vous alors je
veux pas être indiscret tom répondait si
vous voulez mais vous ou vos collègues
vous accepterez volontiers ce vaccin
contre le coronavirus quand il sera
autorisé en france puisque vous faites
partir des personnes prioritaires les
personnels soignants
oui bien sûr je pense que le personnel
soignant n'est pas contre après on est
tous un peu méfiant sécuriser tout à
l'heure par rapport à la gestion de la
crise a pris voilà il va falloir
attendre un petit peu et je pense pour
pour convaincre tout le monde puisque je
les ai eu d'étude où il manque quand
même pas mal de données notamment sur
les effets secondaires donc c'est vrai
que ça ça pose pas mal de questions et
savez je suis moins optimiste que mais
que mes collègues puisque moi
j'entendais plutôt calmes et a priori
60% des français qui hésitaient à se
faire vacciner donc je pense que ça va
être un vrai défi aujourd'hui le seul
vaccin
qu'est ce que vous pourriez répondre
nommé germann on commence la pédagogie
justement rachidi quoi qui nous dit ben
voilà on connaît pas tous sur les effets
secondaires alors j'allais dire les
effets secondaires principaux
apparaissent dans les six semaines après
la vaccination donc là on a un recul
suffisant pour se dire que ce vaccin et
puis les non seulement bien toléré mais
n'a pas de risque mais bien sûr il
existe possiblement un risque
exceptionnel que l'on ne verra que
lorsque plusieurs milliers voire
millions de personnes seront vaccinées
mais un nouveau ce risque exceptionnel
et à mettre en balance avec la gravité
de lakovic 19 notamment pour une
personne à risque est bien le fait de
faire une maladie grave le fait de
décider de l'aco vite n'a rien à voir en
termes de probabilité avec cette
complication exceptionnelle éventuelles
du virus
al'inverse pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas de facteur de risque de faire une
forme grave de l'aco vide il faut savoir
de plus en plus nous observons et
séquelles au concours de la fatigue
de l'essoufflement même des cas de
syndrome inflammatoire poste qu'ovide
nécessite d'ailleurs la
réhospitalisation de ces personnes qui
ont connu une phase virale peu
symptomatiques et donc dans tous les cas
évidemment le risque de complications de
lakovic 19 est bien supérieur un risque
théorique de complications dues aux
accents quand vous entendez que la haute
autorité de santé oms recommande la dès
le début de cette vaccination en
priorité aux ehpad est ce que c'est
vraiment la bonne stratégie adoptée
selon vous denis millet je pense c'est
dans les époques calé les personnes de
plus fragiles parce qu'il ya là j'ai
déjà souvent des comorbidités et puis
également il ya une circulation très
rapide dans les ehpad on le voit chaque
fois que nepad est touché il ya toujours
un peu tout de suite un très grand
nombre de résidents et de personnels qui
sont touchés parce qu'elle proximité le
travail à proximité des lieux fait que
le virus se répand beaucoup donc c'est à
moi de vie logique qu'on commence à
prioriser par ce journal merci en tout
cas à tous les trois ont vu nos bruno
m'égare ban rachidi gouaille denis
millet d'avoir accepté ce débat alors
que la campagne de vaccination est au
feu vert au royaume uni ce sera la
semaine prochaine pour la russie et
prochainement dans notre pays en france
merci à tous les trois et cette crise du
coronavirus en français des derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
14064 4 cos vite détectés en 24 heures
en léger recul par rapport à mercredi
dernier 313 personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit à 18 % comme hier et le
premier minitre jean castex annonce donc
pour sa part des contrôles aléatoires
aux frontières et une quarantaine de
sept jours pour les français annonce
pied à l'étranger écouter les vacances
de sports d'hiver sont l'occasion de
flux de population dans certaines
stations la population passe de 1 à 7
certes les gestionnaires de stations
font tous leurs efforts pour avoir des
protocoles sanitaires adaptés je les en
félicite
mais nous sommes dans la prévention bien
sûr qu'ils veulent bosser je les
soutiens mais je vous préviens le risque
de ne pas avoir de troisième vague en
janvier alors aussi l'autriche a décidé
elle la réouverture des remontées
mécaniques dès le 24 décembre dans les
stations ski françaises elles sont
fermées et durant les fêtes de fin
d'année mesure dénoncé ce matin
bourg-saint-maurice en savoie au maire
des professionnels du ski de la vallée
de la tarentaise manifester aujourd'hui
écouter à leurs réactions
on est tous très amer parce que on est
prêt à être brimé s'il fallait vraiment
faire un effort mais quand on entend
toutes les les français qui vont pouvoir
partir à l'étranger équine et nous on
fait les efforts pour être sûr de
pouvoir finir notre saison on risque de
se faire couper l'herbe sous les pieds
et ne pas pouvoir ouvrir au delà on n'a
pas envie de on veut bien le faire des
efforts mais faut pas nous non nous
prendre pour des idiots parce qu'on voit
tout le monde partir en vacances dans
ces cas là les styles et venir dans nos
montagnes parce que ils seront en
sécurité
disons qu'on a mis tous les
les moyens en place pour pouvoir
accueillir les touristes les acteurs les
élus en fin de compte sont allés voir
les représentants pour pouvoir discuter
de la modalité de l'ouverture des
stations on a tous été pris et puis
vraiment les élus ont été mis en attente
de décision et finalement il n'y a rien
qui ressortent maintien sera une
ouverture terre monte mécanique des
classifications sanitaire s'améliore il
est vrai que le but n'est pas de créer
un cluster dans nos droits dans notre
vallée
il est évident mais il faut que l'on
pense à tous ces professionnels de la
montagne alors survie économique est
resté avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du liban visioconférence
daide humanitaire se soit initiée par
paris en lien avec les actions unis et
puis toujours en france la commission
des affaires étrangères du sénat qui a
écouté auditionné plus tôt hors wang wei
dos le président de l'assemblée
nationale du venezuela qui appellent au
boycott des élections législatives
dimanche dans son pays
[Musique]
oui
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu valable c'est fini pour moi est
ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la
radicalisation mais c'est la
radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde tu répondes
appartement on est énervé dans le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vais m'accrocher passe un tour de
tracteur et cnooc une campagne il faut
savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce 2e au final est ce qu'on pouvait
faire autrement plus vous dépister - les
gens meurent
ça a été vu en allemagne quatre fois
moins de voir qu'en france ça a été vue
un autriche 4 fois moins de morts qu'on
pense à aider vu en corée du sud et
était remplacé ne profite pas de cette
deuxième pont finalement pour dépister
systématiquement les choses vont
recommencer
il aura une troisième vague au printemps
et un troisième confinement et ce pays
sera évidemment cloués au sol
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler qu'au sien un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que si l'histoire de vie et de
mort il faut protéger la végétation faut
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c'est y est n'oublions pas tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise je suis poli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française bienvenue sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez emmanuel
macron mobilise une fois de plus se
mobilisent une fois de plus pour le
peuple libanais une visioconférence
daide humanitaire pour le pays du cèdre
soutient ce soir en présence d'une
trentaine de chefs d'état de ministres
et de omg quatre mois après des
explosions du corps de beyrouth un
deuxième rang des bulles soutien
coprésidée par le président français et
le secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres est à l'ouverture de cette
conférence le chef de l'état français a
réitéré ses exigences de réformes envers
la classe politique libanaise écouter
cette deuxième conférence qui va
permettre donc de compléter la réponse
d'urgence et d'apporter une réponse en
matière de relèvement précoce ne saurait
remplacer l'engagement des forces
politiques libanaises et des
institutions a formé le plus rapidement
possible un gouvernement et à mettre en
oeuvre la feuille de route de réformes
sans laquelle l'aide économique
structurelle internationale ne pourrait
être déclenchée nous ne lâcherons rien
jamais ni sur les promesse que nous
avons faite ni sur nos exigences qu'elle
porte sur les réformes ou l' enquête sur
les origines de l'explosion du port et
lors de la première conférence dette
pour le liban 280 millions d'euros
avaient été récoltés et des fonds pour
éviter que l'économie libanaise ne
s'effondre mais qui reste insuffisant le
pays étant durement éprouvés par la
double explosion du port de beyrouth
dont parle emmanuel macron mais aussi
par une profonde crise politique et la
medjahed je vis là et ça me voir
pour vous aider en tant que peuple pour
vous apporter les médicaments le soutien
de quoi vous nourrirez de quoi vous
aider à reconstruire en avant elle sera
transcende les générations de terrain
elle sera gratuit pour qu'ils n'aillent
pas dans les mains
des habitants en colère contre leurs
dirigeants interpelle le président
français deux jours après la double
explosion de beyrouth
emmanuel macron assure être au liban
pour aider le peuple et non le
gouvernement le président français
trouve les mots justes pour apaiser une
population meurtrie à mois après cette
visite emmanuel macron de retour dans la
capitale libanaise demandent aux
pouvoirs en place de rendre des comptes
le président français annonce même avoir
obtenu un engagement des forces
politiques locales pour la formation
d'un nouveau gouvernement six
rendez-vous de fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons en tirer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien n'a été fait et ce moment là
c'est clair je devrais dire à la
communauté internationale nous ne
pouvons pas être au rendez-vous de
l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanaises
et aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
il n'y a pas de chèque en blanc malgré
cet avertissement
la classe dirigeante libanaises
continuent de faire comme si de rien
n'était le premier ministre désigné
mustapha djette même l'épongé fin
septembre emmanuel macron donne un
nouveau délai de quatre à six semaines à
beyrouth pour former un gouvernement
personne n'a été à la hauteur des
engagements pris le 1er septembre
dernier
tous ont fait le pari du pire dans le
seul but de se sauver eux-mêmes de
sauver les intérêts de leur famille de
leur clan ils n'y parviendront pas à
tous je dis aujourd'hui qu'aucun d'entre
eux ne peut gagner contre les autres je
décide donc de prendre acte de cette
trahison collective et du refus des
responsables libanais de s'engager de
bonne foi dans le contrat que la france
sera proposé le 1er septembre dernier
ils en portent l'entière responsabilité
elle sera lourde ils devront en répondre
devant le peuple libanais
sans résultat saad hariri devient le 22
octobre dernier chef du gouvernement
l'homme est donc de retour à ce poste un
an après avoir démissionné sous la
pression de la rue depuis sa nomination
le liban est toujours sans gouvernement
pollué par de fortes divisions internes
le pays du cèdre n'a donc toujours pas
tenu sa promesse de lancer des réformes
structurelles et une condition pourtant
imposée par le président français pour
le déblocage d'une importante aide
internationale
bien que beyrouth n'est toujours pas
répondu à sa demande emmanuel macron
décide de maintenir la nouvelle
conférence dead au liban une réunion
virtuelle avec une trentaine de chefs
d'état et de gouvernement mais aussi des
ong libanaises des ong qui alerte sur la
situation dramatique
à beyrouth des dizaines de bâtiments
menace aujourd'hui encore de s'effondrer
et des milliers de familles ne peuvent
toujours pas regagné leurs foyers
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis beyrouth avec françois el bacha
économise fondateur de linda news c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir françois el bacha merci d'être
avec nous on vient d'entendre dans ce
sujet toujours pas de gouvernement
vraiment stable au liban cette nouvelle
conférence humanitaire n'est-elle pas un
coup d'épée dans l'eau
bonsoir pas vraiment là cette conférence
est une a été bien cadré s'agit pas
d'une aide économique
tant qu'on n'aura pas de réformes qu'on
n'aura pas de réforme à la fois
économique sur certains secteurs
bancaires etc
il s'agit d'une aide humanitaire il
s'agit de venir en aide à la population
parce qu'en ce moment
économiquement le liban est totale en
exemple on a 39 % des personnes qui sont
au chômage on à 31%
les gens qui ont un travail et ont subi
une perte de salaire et sans parler en
même temps la d2 la dégradation de la
parité
on a deux sources officielles 55% de la
population qui vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté et certaines sources
officieuses évoque le cas de 65% de la
population donc c'est un système
aujourd'hui ou qui en est à
d'effondrement et où la population a
besoin d'une aide humanitaire
le problème c'est que cette aide ne peut
pas passer par les temps est donc
réponse à une urgence humanitaire et non
pas structurelle de la situation c'est
bien ce qu'il faut comprendre tout à
fait tout à fait et surtout qu si les
systèmes avec l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
on a un occident on a des soucis déjà
logistique on arrête les silos appelé
par exemple ont été détruits on essaye
de stocker le blé ou est ce qu on compte
2 etc
et d'ici quelques semaines des réserves
monétaires qui savait à à subventionner
l'achat des produits de première
nécessité seront épuisés les réserves
police terre de la banque du liban
donc on s'attend à une dégradation en
fait dans les semaines à venir de la
parité entre libanaise dollar en raison
de la pression qui va y avoir sur la
monnaie locale
et d'ailleurs on a vu aujourd'hui que
le ministère de l'énergie a augmenté a
commencé à augmenter les tarifs et des
prix sur l'essence
donc c'est assez significatif de ce qui
va venir
c'est à dire c'est à dire que les gens
ont souffert jusqu'à maintenant en 2020
mais le pire n'est pas encore passé
probablement puisque sans réformes
structurelles sans accès à l'aide
internationale
il faut s'attendre à une dégradation
très rapide des conditions sociales et
économiques
jusqu'à quel point parce qu'on l'a vu on
nous le présente dans tous les
reportages en france la situation est
catastrophique au liban cette crise
politique la crise du coc vide
évidemment toutes les catastrophes dont
on parle et jusqu'où peut encore tenir
ce pays
je pense que pour le moment les gens
sont pas encore conscients de la gravité
de la chose parce qu'on est dans un an
dans un momentum on essaie de temporiser
le tout on essaie de gagner du temps la
banque du liban essaie de gagner du
temps l'art et le fait déjà que les prix
des produits pétroliers augmentent ça
permet en même temps de prolonger le
programme de subventions d'achat du blé
des médicaments et ainsi de suite donc
on essaie de gagner du temps la question
c'est combien de temps pour que encore
regagné sa cellule
mais il faut s'attendre à des pénuries
en fait d'aimer déjà des médicaments qui
commence à manquer il ya déjà par utile
le lait infantile qui commence à manquer
et ainsi de suite donc les la majorité
des gens ne se rend pas compte encore de
la gravité de la situation à laquelle on
pourrait rapidement parvenir aujourd'hui
clairement quel est le levier on voit
que la france c'est pour moi voilà
essayer de trouver une solution
au liban il n'y a pas beaucoup de
répondant parce que le gouvernement
peine à sport mais en tous cas de
manière stable d'où peut vous veniez
peut venir le salut la communauté
internationale est beaucoup plus
réaliste que les hommes politiques
libanais qui sont dans le déni ils
démentaient et ça aussi pour le système
bancaire il démentait la gravité de la
crise et on aperçoit de plus en plus que
les pertes par exemple de la banque du
liban sont plus importantes que ce qui
était prévu des pertes du secteur
financier sont plus importantes que
prévu tandis qu'en des personnes
commencement réalisé l'importance des
pertes il reste probablement une
pression sur le système politique sur le
système financier
donc mais le problème c'est que si on en
arrive là
les conséquences seront terribles il
faut pas arriver justement là et on
espère que justement ce système qui se
protègent les dents les autres cracks
tron avant les conséquences sociales et
économiques
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez à
l'attitude du président français voilà
qui tantôt distribuer les bons points
les mauvais points qui organise aussi un
sous l'égide de la france à cette
conférence ce soir qu'est ce que vous
vous dites qu'il a raison ou qui a une
forme d'ingérence les deux dans
l'ingérence au lit dans ses quelque
chose de très commun et à une ingérence
malveillantes comme on a eu pendant des
années ça c'est une ingérence
bienveillant parce que tout simplement
la classe politique et la classe ils ont
voir le système financier n'a pas pris
conscience réellement il ya eu des
conflits d'intérêts en classe politique
et classement et rêver certains hommes
politiques sont également actionnaires
des banques
il veut pas tout simplement reconnaître
la gravité des choses donc c'est un
système aujourd'hui le liban est un
système aujourd'hui politique qui ne
peut pas fonctionner sans ingérence
étrangère en raison des accords de
terrain il a toujours fallu une sorte de
deux mandats de deux personnes qui
disent quoi faire
malheureusement mais la france aussi
dans son attitude bienveillante réclame
aussi des réformes politiques
et justement la fin de ce système où on
a besoin de danse
danse étrangères pour prendre des
décisions
ce qui s'est passé avec les accords de
taef c'est que les prérogatives
présidentielles ont été décalées sur le
conseil des ministres et il faut chaque
fois une sorte d'unanimité pour arriver
à des décisions ce qui n'arrive
pratiquement jamais ce qui ouvre la voie
à de nombreuses négociations entre
partis et donc là à via ces négociations
à des détournements de fonds etc etc
jusqu'à ce que la situation s'aggrave
les normes n'a atteint la situation
s'était aggravée que ce système ne peut
plus perdurer et la france est l'un des
rares pays justement qui le dit
aujourd'hui c'est malheureux d'en
arriver au constat qui veut dire qu'il
faut une ingérence mais à l'heure
actuelle c'est malheureusement la vérité
merci beaucoup françois el bacha de nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage dans vu de
l'extérieur ce soir merci vous remercie
ce mercredi au sénat auditions de roanne
guido par la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées
le président de l'assemblée nationale du
venezuela a renouvelé ses appels au
boycott des élections législatives
prévues dimanche dans son pays à des
élections qu'il juge frauduleuse un
terme qu'il avait utilisée pour
qualifier la présidentielle de 2010 8
qui avait permis la réélection de
nicolas sma doro juan garrido qui en
appellent à l'europe écouter aucun parti
politique ne peut participer en réalité
à ses prochaines élections nous n'avons
plus le
droit de nous présenter aux élections
est ce pour ça que nous non nous parlons
de boycott depuis début 2010 8 l'union
européenne
l'eau est à l'onu ont bien précisé que
le processus n'est pas démocratique et
donc c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui que le sénat français et
tout le monde démocratique nous
accompagnent et exigent des élections
qui nous permettent de sortir de la
crise que nous traversons actuellement
non seulement une crise monétaire mais
ceci n'est qu'une crise démocratique
c'est la première fois que nous que
l'amérique latine se trouve dans cette
situation et pour en parler nous sommes
avec stéphane witkowski
pardon au président du conseil de
gestion de l'institut des hautes études
de l'amérique latine
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous wang wei
d'eau qui s'oppose donc aux élections
législatives alors qu'une partie de
l'opposition assuré ses partisans
d'efficacité de la transparence de ces
élections
pour quelles raisons seahawk hostile
bonsoir
j'écoute et je crois qu'il a toujours
plaidé au fond cette idée que que le le
processus électoral à me dénigrer lien
n'était pas régulier selon lui en
réalité le les élections qui ont lieu
dimanche
la s'inscrivent dans la tradition je
dirais constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que
quand mémoire l'élection a eu lieu en
2015 décembre 2015 qui avait été
remportée par l'opposition vénézuélienne
qui ensuite a été tout de suite acceptée
par nicolas maduro
il se trouve qu'il ya eu un contentieux
si vous voulez par rapport à quatre
députés qui avaient été accrédités
et c'est à partir de là qui a eu une
crise à la fois institutionnelle
politique y compris à l'international
qui se prolonge avec entre temps une
élection de ba d'euros en 2018 et qui
actuellement se poursuit par le fait que
les élections qui arrivent dimanche
d'abord fait l'objet d'un consensus
d'une partie simplement de l'opposition
vénézuélienne
rappelons quand même qu'il ya 107 partis
politiques qui se présente à l'élection
dimanche à quatorze mille candidats il
ya eu trois grands débats électoraux
dans le pays mais il ya toujours eu une
frange de l'opposition radicale qui a
été soutenu et financé par les etats
unis et en particulier l'administration
bush et qui explique cette situation de
blocage qui se situe au niveau
international
j'y voyais d'eau fait campagne auprès du
sénat français sachez que la commission
qui les réunit qui les a il a reçu tout
à l'heure recevra aussi l'ambassadeur du
venezuela en france pour avoir un point
de vue d'éclairer et je dirais équilibré
mais ce ne sont pas les sénateurs
français qui votent dimanche prochain au
venezuela c'était justement mais ma
question pardonnez-moi stéphanois
witkowski parce que on se demande
pourquoi le sénat français c'est vrai
que quand on est moins experts que vous
ayez que ea ya beaucoup de personnes qui
le sont moins vous bien évidemment sur
ce sujet on peut se demander que faire
wang wei dos au sénat français écoutez
c'est la liberté des parlementaires de
recevoir et d'auditionner ce qu'il
souhaite entendre
c'est une position qui effectivement a
rejoint certaines certaines positions
diplomatiques mais qui ne reflètent pas
en tout cas la réalité du terrain
électoral au venezuela le que le sénat
veuille recevoir et est conditionnée
qu'ils entendent c'est son affaire
ce qui est important c'est qu'il y ait
d'autres points de vue que pour que les
sénateurs soit éclairé en bonne en bonne
connaissance de cause je précise que le
système électoral vénézuélien et gérer à
la fois par la commission nationale
électorale qui est indépendante de
l'exécutif donc c'est la constitution
qui prévoit ce processus que d'autre
part il ya des observateurs
internationaux comme en 2018 qui vont
être présents le dimanche et que le lord
d'une table précédent scrutin l'ancien
président carter la fondation jimmy
carter considéré que le processus
électoral vénézuélien était le plus l'un
des meilleurs au monde
et rappelons aussi que le système
électoral venezuela est fondé sur un
système de machine électorale de
machines à côté avec un bulletin
électronique
et c'est un système électoral
relativement fiable
on vient évidemment est ce que mon côté
je a priori ça n'a pas été avérée le
système avait électorale venezuela peut
être contesté par une petite partie de
l'opposition il frange de plus en plus
radicale rappelons que juan garrido et y
avait d'abord été du président de
l'assemblée nationale n'est plus
président depuis le début de l'année
puisque au fond il y avait un système de
rotation interne au sein de l'opposition
donc il n'est plus président de
l'assemblée nationale vénézuélienne
il est simplement candidat autoproclamé
président du venezuela
mais là une partie de plus en plus
important de l'opposition se détache de
cette frange radicale qui a de moins en
moins d'écho dans le pays et qui fait
campagne auprès d'eux je dirais des
grands réseaux internationaux de presse
il ya l'étranger alors vous parlez des
observateurs internationaux qui seront
présents sur place mais pas l'union
européenne qui a décidé de repousser
d'invitation de l'état avait des yeux et
d'un est-ce qu'on doit avoir la main des
états unis en dessous alors l'union
européenne il ya une position il ya
certains pays de l'union européenne qui
ne sont pas sur cette ligne là le
l'union européenne s'est en grande
partie aligné sur la la diplomatie et
robes en tout cas sur cette affaire et
c'est pour pour je pense probablement
pour des raisons de de stature et de
position l'union européenne ce ne ne
soit pas se déjuger par rapport à une
validation peut être un peu rapide du
statut de droit noyau en tant que
président autoproclamé dans le sillage
de certains pays dont la france
l'espagne et quelques autres mais pas
tous les pays de l'union européenne
d'une part mais probablement l'union
européenne doit probablement prendre le
temps pour pouvoir revenir à une
reconnaissance des réalités de terrain
sur le plan électoral vénézuélien
rappelé
aussi que pour prendre une image l'union
européenne s'était un peu figé par
exemple dans une position vis à vis de
cuba
une disposition dite commune qui a duré
une quinzaine d'années et au bout de 15
ans l'union européenne a fini par
changer de cap et reconnaître que cette
stratégie n'avait pas produit de
résultats et avait été une position qui
a été révisée elle peut donc imaginer
aussi que d'autres pays du monde savait
que l'onu l'onu en tant que qui
représente le point de vue de la grande
majorité des pays dans le monde
africains asiatiques et une grande
partie de pays d'amérique latine ne
reconnaissent pas monsieur wade comme
président autoproclamé du venezuela
merci stéphane avides cofsky président
du conseil de gestion de l'institut des
hautes études de l'amérique latine
d'avoir été avec nous et dans le reste
de l'actualité l'immigration clandestine
vers l'europe un rêve pour de nombreux
africains au sénégal certains prennent
la mer sur les pirogues de fortune pour
rejoindre les îles canaries souvent au
péril de leur vie
un phénomène en explosion dans le port
de hambourg grâce d'aia
si dieu ne décide pas de ta mort alors
tu reste en vie la mort saliou l'a vu de
près
comme lui ils sont des centaines à
tenter leur chance à chaque traversée au
départ du port de bourg
l'un des principaux points de départ des
migrants pour les canaris avec son frère
fin octobre ils ont embarqué sur une
pirogue dont le moteur a cassé sur 200
passagers ils ne sont que 51 avoir
survécu
le feu n'était pas trop fort lorsqu un
bidon d'essence a explosé
j'ai laissé mes bagages je me suis jeté
à l'eau certains passagers qui ne savait
pas nager se sont agrippés à moi nous
avons nager nager et autour de nous les
gens se noyait c'était terrible un
phénomène qui ne date pas d'hier et qui
a été accentuée par la crise économique
puis celle du co vide 19 pour une
traversée chaque migrant doit payer
entre 300 et 500 euros à des passeurs
nous avons dénombré plus de 400
carrément vous imaginez les zones où les
jeunes à plein de l'âge qui devrait
contribuer le plus quel est le parent
vie et du coup ils ont gaspillé comme ça
la vie
ils ont mentionné comme ça l'a vu des
conditions qui n'empêche pas les
candidats à l'exil de continuer à rêver
depuis janvier près de 18000 personnes
auraient rejoint les canaris selon
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
en plus de la crise bourg ville de
pêcheurs est minée par la concurrence
avec des licences attribuées d'abord aux
navires européens et chinois beaucoup
mieux équipés
au fil des erreurs qu'on part en mer et
à notre retour
ce qu'on gagne couvrent à peine ce qu'on
a dû dépenser il n'y a rien pour nous
ici et c'est pour cela que nous
préférons tout quitter pour partir c'est
la seule manière d'aider nos parents
notre famille n'est guère évolué à
polonais ou un notaire pour la saône est
fan une parade à ces deux derniers mois
500 personnes seraient mortes en tentant
la traversée
un voyage d'environ 1500 km qui peut
durer de sept à dix jours
le gouvernement tente selon lui des
actions dissuasives et plus de 10 jours
les équipes sont sur le terrain que ce
soit ici amour c'est lui ou dans le sud
pour essayer d'identifier d'abord le
nombre de jeunes qui sont pas
le nombre de rescapés et le nombre de
personnes potentiellement candidats au
départ l'état aussi en train de mettre
en place des outils qui vont dissuader
les jeunes de partir notamment
n'arrêtons les passeurs car il faut le
dire le mot ce sont des criminels et il
faut les traiter comme tel selon des
estimations
seule une pirogue sur trois arriverait
aux canaries mais l'exode massif
persiste une réalité qui contraste avec
les promesses de créations d'emplois du
président macky sall dans ce pays de 16
millions d'habitants
20 % des 15-24 ans sont au chômage et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup de l'avoir suivi vous retrouver
dans quelques minutes david khalifa pour
un point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sens